hey guys hey what's up I Luigi everyone
hey it's me guys today we're reviewing
the paddle wizard a movie review movie
repeating first of all let's look at the
poster Wow why would anyone watch this
you might ask I don't know sometimes I'm
just so random that's why I'm a complete
man like hey let's watch that movie the
absolute man like this is from 1977 and
it's actually a really good time
thoroughly enjoyed this film I liked
this review saying that it's some of the
worst editing I've ever seen you don't
understand okay it's awesome right name
but without further ado let's break it
down
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it that's all the intro for the
movie and it just starts that's good
editing okay I don't want to hear about
every single person that is part of this
film if I'm already deciding to watch it
okay
this movie was ahead of its time now it
starts off with a lovely story of
changhua I don't remember his name I
don't know if that's racist for me to
just make up a name wasn't quite of a
pickle he finds out that his mistress is
pregnant
oopsie then literally seconds away from
him finding out that she's pregnant
this guy just jumps
[Music]
wait poet this movie doesn't waste time
okay he's barely just gone damn that
sucks
ah maybe it was East dropping maybe
actually no I think about it he probably
was watching them but then again he
doesn't make sense for him to barge him
after they had sex and after she said
that it doesn't matter she may think
your side's okay it's a standard kung fu
film oh no no oh no no it gets
infinitely better very fast the knees
that's right
why does he shoot this man from his
fingers with lasers on this man's both
knees I don't know does anyone know
please let me know in the comments your
top five reasons brittle just poison and
eating honey younger
ha so he tries to escape but you can't
escape the knee gun okay you just can't
[Music]
you know someone's trying to escape what
do you do you shoot off their knees
that's what needs to be done this is me
when I get my knees fired off by a
finger laser and that was that I heard
you were in a fight five seconds after
it happened this movie doesn't waste
time did she hear the actual fight or
did she hear gossip of there being a
fight while the fight was happening I'm
so confused
it doesn't matter what a fool I look
that way twenty okay I'll break it down
this is her fiance the other one is like
hey who the hell are you get out and
he's like I don't care jun-chan
that's the thing I apologize
survival
damn this in troy's fire it's another
example of perfect editing you have this
man sitting in a cage 20 years later
he's still wearing the same yellow robe
because he's known as yellow robe man of
course what other name would he have I
don't think he broke your legs I think
he fired them up I think you have no
legs spot the swamp way
[Music]
[Applause]
plant it and now we see the power of the
new that's right everybody
damn so basically the plot is that 20
years later the son of the man that shot
off his knees doesn't want to learn kung
fu he wants to be a scholar he doesn't
understand the nonsensical violence he
just want to be peaceful the daughter of
the mistress has grown up to be a I
don't know I don't know what she is and
her mom says that if she ever finds the
wife of the man that she had her child
she has to kill her
she was also cover up her face why why
why would they cover up my face men are
bad news did you not watch the Gillette
commercial don't make me laugh so the
son of the knee shooting man decides to
go out in the world to learn about new
things and it's the first time he goes
outside the palace what is the first
thing he sees way of course a lady with
a bunch of [ __ ] snakes you know if
I've never left my house before and
that's the first thing I see I probably
would just go back inside but that's
just me
they claim hung food together and
obviously he's terrible but she
basically says you don't really need to
practice just in case you happen to
stumble upon a red scaled snake just
suck him up and you'll get his power
great how convenient it why should they
get attacked by a bunch of ninjas and
apparently he decided to change his
haircut and complete appearance he has a
different robe even the snakes are pee
okay I don't know what they do
but no snakes I've seen enough hentai to
know where this is going am i right who
would win two armless people or an
entire army
[Music]
hmm the snakes of course
just throw snakes I hear you go to
personate go super snake okay that's
just nasty I'm sorry but you disgusting
[Music]
[Applause]
so chang chong a manages to escape and
he's supposed to get help but he gets a
box mysterious box that he needs to
deliver to the friend of this woman
what's inside the box Felix Oh Oh we'll
get you that don't worry
so he runs over to the snake girl to get
some help but he's been attacked at the
same time
do it yeah they say that
[Music]
what radar cumulative Munna so yeah yeah
Calibos here
she should all hide sure yeah boy see
how she turns out sure yo you a cool
name Cunha and I gotta say finally a
strong female protagonist finally you
did it right
1977 China you did it right now the
first girl had snakes as her weapon the
second girl has guess what as a weapon
that's right everyone a blanket not the
blanket please the blanket did that can
stop swords amazing Wow incredible
[Music]
she then pulls out the greatest weapon
of all time so we had snakes
we have blankets now what do we have
what possibly couldn't she pull out a
bone a bone that shoots lasers epic
[Music]
where did that girl even come from and
why did she shoot her in the ass was the
girl in all of this I think she just
shot her gardener oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll say now and I'm gonna say it at a
couple other points this movie was
plagiarized by Star Wars this is
basically Chinese Star Wars we got
lasers we got nice shooting just like
Star Wars and we will get through the
rest of the points eventually one thing
that I appreciate about this movie is
that they just jump everywhere let's go
and they're on a horse let's go okay so
the next point so they get attacked
again by another ninja gang and out
comes in to the rescue look at that
that's Star Wars come on it's even
sounds the same in comes to rescue
however is cheng-chun it was given this
box it doesn't know what it does it
doesn't know what's inside of it but for
some reason he decides to just pull it
out and this is what happens
sleepy I just saw it jumpers out bytes
the man in the neck and then jumps back
in what a polite frog
what a nice trained frog is that a thing
in China maybe that's the thing in China
that I don't know about you Chinese Star
Wars everyone I gotta say though as bad
as and completely nonsensical there's a
movie is the action it's actually pretty
good sometimes when it's at about
blanket and Saints and boom laser what
the hell is that she's back
what does she have maracas what are
those maracas girl had for revenge
oh no we're not the girls nah this movie
is just like Star Wars I've been saying
it so many times when will people listen
George Lucas and Rick this movie off he
turned it into a billion dollar
enterprise and China is out for revenge
it all makes sense now I don't really
like the lobster guy so I'm just gonna
ignore him he's is annoying all you need
to know is he's a lobster guy I don't
and he's I don't
he's a lobster guy okay thanks ninja
bone dog bone ninja girl
[Music]
which means that he has to suck out the
poison from the lobster claw and it's
it's kind of weird like this is supposed
to be romantic this is why is this
sexual China
[Music]
just like Star Wars oh I just realized
actually they're siblings just like Star
Wars oh my god there's no one gonna talk
about this is no one gonna mention this
am I the only one with a small chub
right going damn that's hot yeah
[Music]
so five seconds after that beautiful
sucking little segment the red scale
snake appears hooray - no Tim suck out
the blood
[Music]
you know in the matrix when Neil learns
kungfu through a very similar aspect of
basically no training just per automatic
he knows kung fu
same thing happens in this plot so I
guess you can say matrix stole from this
movie as well may we have the famous
scene of neo saying I know kung foo here
however we have a much better line this
is good news
I know martial arts The Matrix stole
from Jiang watch out why is that racist
that's what he said though Jing wah wah
wah wah wah I know kung fu this is good
news yeah we ain't so tough
so she swore that anyone that sees her
without the mask she has to marry
otherwise she has to kill them so she's
like hey you want to be my husband and
it's one of the nicest moments I've ever
seen I'm willing to marry you
well you ain't you eat you truly makes
my heart pound deeper and deeper of love
and affection that was beautiful I'll be
Tori there's that good day in Chinese
those nipples are distracting this shot
is this awful it's just horrible to look
at what the [ __ ] are they doing they're
gonna want all your Disney
[Music]
and he's back the greatest character of
all time he's called yellow robe man but
he should really be called me man those
are some goddamn needs I want those legs
please Ike where do I get those they're
amazing
I really appreciate shots like these
also they're filming whatever this is
oh there she is okay
great there she has found her alone in
this shot you can basically see the
stilts he never lost his legs everyone
so their capture Cheng Zhong and secret
ninja lady and they say hey why kill
them when that's exactly our goal when
we can just feed them to the gorillas
feed them to the gorillas and I know
this is gonna be surprising but another
example of ripping off Star Wars don't
worry I am as well oh my God he's back
where did he come from what just
happened there why did he fly in I need
to see where did he come from I love it
so much
[Music]
okay how is this not like Star Wars
remember in episode 6 is it episode 6
when they're thrown down in the pit to
fight the giant monster same point same
flight instead of a giant monster
there's a gorilla that's the small
detail but otherwise it's exactly the
same George Lucas I'm on to you look
identical
[Music]
it's I benthic oh okay
show framerate great nicely done
it's a colorful fighting gorilla
incredible that's a lot of laughing in
this movie now the yellow Romain has
only begun to show his power level he
also has that
oh my god
[Music]
haha
George Lucas again basically the same as
the lightsaber no not the finger
let's goddamn fingers I don't say man I
just I don't see just like servers so
they're about to die from the gorilla
and she's like eight eat the toes and he
doesn't even hesitate he's like yeah I
guess I'll eat the toad she hasn't even
explained why you're supposed to eat the
toad he's just like yeah I guess I'll
eat the toad you know why I know I'm
dying from a gorilla beating me to death
but I'll eat the toad okay you maybe
should have said that before or telling
me to eat encode eat the coat eat the
tote don't eat the toad for sleepy Oh No
and now he has the power of toad and
snake and oh my god what is that attack
what is that
what guerrilla no take just take his arm
you didn't have to do that
Oh angel
you have now acquired superpower you
have basically gone super saiyan you can
kill with your bare hands
your reaction please this is great
Craig how is this not like Star Wars you
go ahead and tell me is this a common
thing in China I do something I never
been to China I don't know if this is
what you do but I
did he just shoot him in the knee he did
not just shoot him in the knee again
what that's my move this way we should
copy strike George Lucas and I can copy
strike there's a movie now they escape
the pit and it's time for the final
battle see they always go for the needs
of china-us Oh Mike yeah I forgot about
that
Kearney had said something cooler like
Dragons flame rah no it had to be oh my
God he's at it again what is happening
if it's red dragon soul then why does
that beam the green now of course the
movie had to sneaking a couple more knee
attacks I don't know what is up with
Chinese people in the attacks but I'm
wearing kneepads which I can't wear but
if I had knees I would you know what
never mind look at white saw was that
necessary another knee attack another
knee attack
[Music]
Jesus clients I want those legs you see
you clearly see it like here but hey oh
my god I want that I want it okay thanks
oh don't shoot up his leg again he did
not do it and then he dies I don't know
it's pretty it's pretty gross it's the
semanas they they like to do weird I
don't know I don't know why they do that
and then the movie is over it rides off
into the sunset with snake snake
snake Sun is his true love come next and
that everyone wish the paddle wizard I
think that was the name of the film when
I think I learned a lot here today
[Music]
and that is
I'm sure there's some message to be
taken from this now I know a lot of
people are gonna be like why why are you
watching it would be so weird associated
well I actually really liked it I think
it's so nice that what people criticized
it for was the bad editing this movie
wasted no time and I really appreciated
that I'm sick and tired of watching
movies these days and you know exactly
how the plot is gonna pan out it just
bores me to death with this movies like
these you never know what's gonna happen
so hey if you have an afternoon and want
to have some good laughs with your
friend I recommend watching the battle
wizard and you can learn more about
snakes gorillas and sucking things out
now I hope you guys enjoyed this video
it's mine so like if you did and if you
want more epic movie reviews like this
one and I'll see you guys tomorrow
you could bye everyone bye bye bye bye I
must go
[Music]